i don't mind being touched yeah me  either right and i like touching i i but  i feel like whenever i touch  definitely charlie which we talked about  yeah yeah but glenn even i feel like of  the three of us like you're the most  approachable and sort of like the the  most lovable the most lovable of the  three of us and i'm probably the least  and yet like in real life i enjoy touch  i think more than even you guys like if  i get approached by a fan of the show  like i always expect them to be a little  like  is this guy gonna yell at me you know  and you might but they don't well i  might but it won't be because it won't  be because you're  it won't be because you're nice it'll be  because you're a dick  i'm fine with the mutually accepted  touch situation that's when it comes out  it's more